in our effort to get as many people out
as fast as we can uh while we had the uh
the airport uh functioning uh we focused
on doing just that
and
we're doing accountings on the back end
uh as people arrive in the united states
that's your secretary of state admitting
that he didn't care about vetting these
folks before we brought them
to u.s soil and if you thought they
would be securely held on u.s military
bases well think again in an ingram
angle exclusive afghan war vet and
congressman mark green shared a letter
he just sent
to secretary blinken i've recently been
made aware of someone at fort pickett
virginia that afghan evacuees basically
have free reign of the complex and they
have even been allowed to leave despite
not having
completed the vetting process my source
has made shocking allegations including
multiple incidents of sexual assault and
several evacuees have been picked up by
uber drivers without any permission from
authorities or being cleared to leave
congressman mark green joins me now
congressman uh that they're being um
the records are being looked at on the
back end
was stunning enough
but what you're reporting tonight is
truly shocking
laura it's crazy and it's not just fort
pickett i'm talking to sources that are
at multiple locations you know the real
challenge here is directions from state
you know dod is getting its directions
on how to handle these situations by the
state department and the state
department is failing to give them
adequate information they're they're
letting them leave they can catch an
uber and actually leave the base they
don't know exactly how many are even
there so they can't account for someone
if they don't return
and they're telling the people oh if you
go and you don't come back well that
will end your visa processing
but if they want free they're gone
there's nobody keeping them from leaving
and then you get the shocking
allegations of harassment and sexual
assault and it's just it's horrific well
congressman isn't it also the case as
the new york times reported over the
weekend
that many of these individuals arrived
in the united states with no documents
yes
when when millie says oh no they're
going through several levels of
databases
against what we don't know who they are
yeah we don't have biometrics on a good
portion of these people and we can't
really get
information from state because they
won't provide names they won't provide
any information on the people the
numbers that they have they won't even
tell us how many american citizens they
evacuated we tried to get that number uh
you know requested through the national
defense authorization act the other day
and and i couldn't get that passed
it's just crazy this state department is
a complete failure
well here's how dhs secretary mayorkas
thinks that the vetting is actually how
it's going
we're dealing with very very few people
that have given us any cause
for concern the taliban when they took
control released thousands of prisoners
including members of isis and al-qaeda
can you guarantee that none of those
prisoners are making their way into the
united states i can guarantee you that
we are doing everything possible to make
sure that they don't
but congressman it's clear that they
aren't and we have thousands and
thousands just 10 miles from here at
dulles airport on the 20th anniversary
of 9 11. we don't know who a lot of
these individuals are is that not true
that is absolutely true there are many
of them that have zero documentation at
all a very large number of them like 20
30 percent
well and it turns out that
anyone who got onto those airplanes
because of a humanitarian concern
someone uh you know pushed their way up
to the front or was infirm and a lot of
people were infirm they were there for
hours and days it was a terrible awful
scene heartbreaking
but the fact of the matter is a lot of
individuals it was reported were
grabbing women and children and say oh
this is my wife
but we have no record to show that they
actually are even related same thing
happening at our southern border is that
not the case that is that is absolutely
true we don't have any documentation we
can't prove that family units i mean
they can do dna tests but unfortunately
these people are just being allowed to
leave the the contonent areas they can
just get up and and walk out and that's
from multiple sites not just picket um
and and they're not
they're not tracked they're not
accounted for
we have no way of knowing who they are
and we've had talks with people who are
saying they know taliban is in some of
these flights so this is one of the
greatest security risks this nation has
ever had and this president and state
department don't seem to care oh there i
mean tony blinken looks like he's he's
being held hostage okay half the time
congressman uh we're going to stay on
this the state department had no
response to your letter we reached them
and we tried to reach them and zero
response hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else